A story is something out of a movie.
A reputed Italian mob
boss on the run
was hiding in plain sight.
As a pizza chef, after 16 years,
six year
old Edgardo
Greco has been captured in France.
He had adopted a new identity,
and one is even featured
in a local paper
as, quote, an authentic Italian
pizza maker.
In reality, authorities
say he was a hit man
for one of the most powerful Italian
criminal networks.
Greco was wanted
for the killing of two brothers
from a rival gang back in the 1990s.
It's the second
big Mafia arrest this year
after Matteo was seen
not was picked up in Sicily,
if you remember, last month.
Let's get to Barbie Nadeau,
who is in Rome with more on this arrest.
And Barbie, I mean, what a story.
How did they catch him?
How much did
ego play a part here, Barbie?
Ego played a huge role in his demise,
let's say.
They were really honing in on him
since about 2019, they say.
But he was a prolific
social media poster.
He had created this sort of alter ego.
We took a closer look at the arrest
His name is
Edgardo Greco, a hit man
from the Calabrian Ndrangheta mafia,
caught after 16 years of eating Italian
justice.
Despite being on Italy,
an Interpol wanted list
for allegedly killing
two brothers
with iron bars
and dissolving their bodies in acid,
he was living under an alias
and working as a pizza maker in France.
He was even featured in a local newspaper
and posted selfies on social media.
His ego leading to his downfall.
Greco.
The arrest follows that of Mafia
super boss
Matteo Messina, denaro
last month after 30 years in hiding.
Authorities have uncovered hideouts
decorated with mafia movie posters
and luxury items.
Journalist and author
Roberto Saviano
has been living under police protection
since his book Gomorrah
about the Mafia, was published in 2006.
He tells us that it's normal
for these bosses
undercover to still want attention.
And then, of course, a typical
look at El Chapo when he was working,
he wanted to meet Sean Penn,
who he wanted to make a movie about him.
Al Capone wanted to go to the movie
set of Scarface Primo Scarface, and.
But despite these high profile arrests,
there are still dangerous Mafiosi
in hiding.
This man, Giovanni Motsi,
has been convicted of murder
and Mafia Association in Sicily.
He's been on the run since 1998.
Renato Tinker,
Gunilla of the Neapolitan Camorra
has been on the run since 2002
after being
convicted of murder, weapons
charges and extortion.
Italy's anti-mafia squad
say they're working around the clock
to find those still in hiding
and to
make sure those recently
convicted of Mafia crimes
don't get a chance to get away.
And when you look at that, you know,
there are
there are still these dangerous
people out there.
And the Italian authorities
tell us that they are focused on them.
No, not just because they've got one
or two behind bars.
It's really the focus to get everyone
and to stop anyone from getting away
next time. Isa.
Yeah, and I bet
and I bet
the Carabinieri are celebrating. Really?
They've had two arrests
in several weeks or so. Several months.
How much has social media here
played a part What are they telling you?
Well, you know, these
these are the guy that was just arrested
in France, was posting on social media
about what a great pizza chef he was.
You know,
when you talk to these anti-mafia
investigators, obviously,
they're not going to give away
all the secrets
of how they're finding these people.
But they do call them social media.
They do try to
to follow the connections of people
who they know are protecting them.
They make a lot of arrests
around the protective network.
They try to sequester
assets and money and close bank accounts
and all of that.
But everything you know,
nothing happens in a vacuum these days.
Everything is sort of out there.
And so
say you've got someone helping protect
a mafia boss
who's posting on social media
that may just get
the big guy in trouble, too.
And police here are looking
not just leaving any stone unturned.
These are clearly
and for many, many years.
Bobby Dando, great to see you, Bobby.
Appreciate it. Thank you.